clams usually have one line of defense
against a predator
they're tough shells but this researcher
just discovered that this clam the disco
clam may have a unique defense mechanism
a mesmerizing white shell the fact that
this clam was opening in the middle of
an attack to flash at the predator made
no sense to us especially given that the
predator is the fearsome mantis shrimp
known for it's incredibly powerful punch
I got hit once and you know was bruised
for a month but when the disco clam
meets a mantis shrimp Dougherty
discovered something bizarre the mantis
shrimp itself they actually went into a
catatonic state for up to 15 minutes so
I think this is one of the greatest
matchups in the animal kingdom can you
talk about the combatants we have one on
both sides they're two very popular and
very unique creature is so mantis shrimp
are not technically shrimp they're
taxonomic group is tomato pods so there
are two main types they're smashers
which smash things so they usually feed
on hard-bodied prey things like clams
snails and then there are Spears which
sort of look like the Edward
Scissorhands I suppose at the underwater
world in this case because we're dealing
with a clam or a hard body predator we
study the Smashing mantis shrimp which
can actually hit at the speed of a six
caliber bullet and cause cavitation
underwater so it's a quite unique strike
it does strike with such force that it
creates these cavitation bubbles can you
walk us through what those are and and
what happens when they explode easiest
ways to explain it is sort of that they
essentially boil the water it's actually
creating an area of low volume and that
creates this boiling and when that
bubble collapses it actually can create
a shock wave that can stun their prey
items they can actually break aquarium
glass we had this happen it's a very
interesting evolutionary adaptation to
feed on things that are traditionally
hard to get at like a clam that has a
thick calcium carbonate shell so
switching to the the clams what is a
disco clam and why is it called such
Disko claims a type of file clam disco
is a colloquial term people also call
them flames caliphs or electric scallops
they are technically a clam not a
scallop but they live in the
indo-pacific on coral reefs and what
they typically do is they find a small
hole that they can get inside and
they'll use Bissell threads to attach
themselves inside that hole and then
they'll stick out their tentacles and
they'll be flashing anytime there's
ambient light so one side of the tissue
is reflective it actually has tiny
silicon nano spheres which if you think
about it are essentially like teeny tiny
disco balls inside their tissues that
are really effective at reflecting light
and then on the other side it's
absorbent so they basically show the
reflective side and then hide it
almost like an audience doing away but a
football game and that's why to our eyes
when it happens very quickly it looks as
though they're flashing and they speed
up when you scare them or give them food
so anything that sort of excites them
will speed up that flashing display and
this is it's fundamentally different
from how most other critters in the sea
who that produce white are going about
it how is this different from
bioluminescence a lot of people actually
thought it was bioluminescence initially
the difference is you can see it during
the day and usually bioluminescence
isn't bright enough to be seen during
the day this is based fully on structure
within the tissue whereas
bioluminescence is a chemical reaction
that actually produces light instead of
heat so yeah it's quite different it's
quite unique and you did a study
recently that looked at this matchup
between the mantis shrimp and the disco
clam what did you find in this study so
the most interesting interaction was the
disco clam opening mid attack so when
you think about a clam they're usually
their best liner defenses there shell
right they can close very tightly as
anyone who's ever tried to open one
knows and so the fact that this clam was
opening in the middle of an attack to
flash at the predator made no sense to
us right like that's your best you know
line of defense when you're being
attacked by this voracious predator the
mantis shrimp itself also has a very
strange reaction to that red
external tissue they actually went into
a catatonic state for up to 15 minutes
given that the mantis shrimp goes into
this catatonic state might that open it
up to its own predation like that's kind
of this weird symptom of the disco clam
doing its thing and and then the
predator itself gets eaten there's
clearly something going on that the
mantis shrimp is very unsure of when
they encounter this tissue so that's why
you know we wanted to look at the tissue
further and see if we could figure out
what was going on then read it so unique
and unpalatable so the mantis shrimp is
famous for being a voracious predator
it's eating a lot of different things in
the sea are there any indications that
it's you know off-put by any other
potential prey items other than the
disco claim they're not what I would
call picky eaters
I know my PhD I fed one a blue ringed
octopus which has enough to trudeau
toxin to kill adult humans so not
something most people would willfully
eat the fact that we saw this strange
interaction with the disco clam
fascinated us from a behavioral point of
view because there's just not much that
we'll sort of throw off the mantis
shrimp especially to the point of going
into a catatonic state and cleaning
their mouthparts and just clearly being
very annoyed and what they worried the
countering I think it's also interesting
because these are you know intelligent
as we can define it creatures that I've
seen them actually blow limbs off of
crabs and things like that they're
crafty animals and it's interesting to
see them kind of fall to pieces when I
come across this go clean yeah so they
can be very manipulative with the
morphology of any creature that they
encounter I think they have to be in
order to get various things open and
avoid getting hurt themselves while
they're predating upon something so to
see them not only go catatonic but just
seem to be completely lost you know I
don't know how to deal with this bright
red clam that's flashing at me I don't
know what to do with this it's a pretty
fascinating behavior to encounter and in
general animals usually don't do
something unless there's some sort of
benefit to them right you don't want to
expend too much energy unless it
benefits you in some manner it's not
always the case but most of the time
that
true so it could be that this flashing
you know is just a really catchy
evolutionary thing to sort of show
predators don't eat me
you'll regret it it's also gonna ask
about the evolutionary side of things I
mean could it be that the disco clam has
evolved this defense specifically for
something like a mantis shrimp to be
able to confuse it one thing that's
really important in animal behavior is
to remember to consider the visual
capability of the predator you're
assuming is attacking right so all these
different groups that could potentially
eat disco clams all have different
visual capacity management particularly
sixteen photoreceptors which you know we
as humans have three so they've got us a
little bit beat there this is an
indo-pacific species that has evolved
this display and indo-pacific reefs are
incredibly colorful and you sort of have
to do a lot to stand out right so if
you're trying to advertise that your
poisonous are distasteful you have to be
creative in order to do it given the
uniqueness of the structure and the
disco clan that's that's producing this
light might there be some inspiration
here for human designs for disco balls
or otherwise yes I mean I like to say
that anything we can do nature does
better there's a lot that we can learn
about structural coloration from things
like morpho butterflies that use you
know a very specific interaction between
tissue and light in order to create
really amazing displays of color so
there's actually a Qualcomm display
that's based on you know movable mirrors
that can create sort of more light when
there's a bright light outside so if you
think about using a tablet you know if
you're trying to read a book on your
tablet and you go outside and there's
too much light you suddenly can't see
the screen and if we learn from nature
and how animals use structural
coloration given more ambient light the
screen can actually get brighter if that
screen itself can interact with the
light that's coming in so with disco
clams
you know we initially studied the the
size of the silicon nano spheres their
spacing against one another all of that
showed us is
essentially that they're optimized for a
blue light environment and that their
reflection is really quite impressive
for a natural animal and spectrometry we
look at something called a white
standard which essentially should
reflect every color of the visible
spectrum which gives you white so the
disco clam was quite close to that you
know ideal standard and it's it's pretty
amazing to have a reflector that that is
that powerful especially underwater
where your light environment is quite
limited so in the ocean being able to
reflect you know the entire visible
spectrum is particularly impressive
because red light attenuates so quickly
as to other wavelengths as you go a
little bit deeper the thing that I was
most interested in is the actual
flashing display and unfortunately the
disco clam is the only by valve I know
of that has anything like that so in a
perfect world I would love to look at
different potential predators and see
how they measure up against the disco
clown but yeah it's something that we
can potentially do in the future
I guess generally speaking that disco
clam is staying alive I'm sorry I'll
show myself out now thanks for being
here with us thanks for having me
[Music]